we are celebrating cookie week here on
our show cookies are so happy and what a
better way to do that than to bake some
with someone fantastic our next guest is
an actress television house and author
of life from scratch family traditions
that start with you and she's an amazing
wife and mother please welcome vanessa
lachey
[Applause]
that i've sort of destroyed it but then
i think oh that's kind of the point
yeah because this is so interactive your
book thank you it has
lists and playlists and recipes and
really amazing tips about
pretty much every holiday you could
think of it's like a cliff notes guide i
think to
a year in your life my mom left when i
was eight years old and i struggled with
what do i do how do i go to a party and
what gifts do i buy and i wore a white
dress to a wedding and i didn't know you
weren't supposed to do that
so um i just had this kind of aha moment
where i just decided that my messy past
wasn't gonna define my future and i was
in power of creating my own destiny and
that's when i had my first son who is
now nine then i had my daughter who was
six that terrified me as well because
there was no mother-daughter
relationship and then my son baby
phoenix is
and i want to give them the best life
and be the best mom
in spite of not having one myself
i love that you're creating the life
that you want for your children and then
sharing that with everybody else you
know the book is like a black and white
guide for you it's not what you should
do it's just a guide to help you create
your own version of what we do in the
lache family and so i i have to force
myself to create daily habits monthly
habits yearly habits for my family that
now have in turn become our traditions
which are what we look forward to it's
the comfort my kids find it's the love
that binds my friends and i so um i've
just found how important look we're
making the cookies i'm gonna make for
you today well let's make them because
it's true like
don't we all crave
at any age to feel safe to have
traditions to kind of know where things
are coming and going to feel heard to be
included and um
and that's this like my kids you know
kids what kid doesn't want cookies
during the holidays so um this is super
easy by the way everything in the book
is super easy and foolproof and i'm like
i'm not a suit like i'm not a chef i
like to put on music drink wine and cook
in the kitchen
so if there's a word for that that's me
your husband
can i just talk about there was two
pictures that one
and this one
he really is in love with you i mean
it's just amazing he's the whole book is
him like looking at you
and like i guess i kind of forced that i
was like i don't think you can fake
these looks i'm telling you the
chemistry in this book is so hot i was
like should i get back on that dating
app i'm not kidding
yes you should
you're talking about family once the
second the 50 shades of lache
romantic this book i was like okay
i know i'm looking at your beautiful
children but i'm also looking at the way
your husband's looking at you and that's
why the children came exactly
that's how it happened
um so these cookies these cookies are an
easy cookie i'm sure you all have had
these peanut butter blossoms or you've
made them they're so easy um
you let the butter sit at room
temperature which is a trick that i
learned you just leave it out i would
always put it in the microwave and it
would melt you're like no you just leave
it out i'm like for hours and hours they
said yeah you can do that with butter so
you let it get room temperature we've
got our mixer here with sugar we're
gonna add in an egg
some um vanilla extract
what do we got here i think it's a
little milk
see i don't even have my recipe i have
to pull up all my recipes when i cook by
the way vanessa i'm not the lady that's
like oh we just eyeballed it all you
can't eyeball baking um we're gonna
slowly add this mixture it's like flour
um baking soda salt it's it's all sifted
together which i let the kids do because
i try to find easy things that they can
do and this cookie recipe is one so
ultimately we're gonna get this dough
and then this is also the fun part i do
the scooping oh you're right over there
you're a woman after my own heart i
really this is so look here this i'll do
your brooklyn and and i'm mom okay here
you go baby we're gonna make these into
little balls
so there you go and she does that and
then we put them on the tray and smart
then i just scoop this is a martha
stewart trick this is not a vanessa
lachey trick i mean if more if it's
man
then what we're going to do is we're
going to pop these in the oven for i
want to say about eight minutes and then
they're gonna come out these are already
lukewarm they've been sitting here
because we've been talking but you're
going to take your little chocolate kiss
and this is where the kids get involved
and they just push it on
these look so
moist which i know is a word people are
weird about but
test oh it's um of like sitting there
that's why we're going to put them back
in for two to three minutes okay this
part i will say um for the moms at home
i have to put a towel here because the
kids little hands this is a hot pan oh
that's insane they burn but i still want
them to be involved but i also don't
want to burn my children you know one of
those things
so then we pop these back in for two
minutes two to three minutes and
honestly you think oh it's going to melt
and it's going to be a big mush no it's
not
oh my god
[Applause]
peanut butter blossom cookies cheers
cheers peanut butter cheers peanut
butter cheers a soft chocolate center oh
my god
oh my god
if you throw this in the mix i think
you're doing really well
i what trial is not called lovely this
isn't even in the book guys
this is incredible i know oh my god you
guys hit the book though
you guys this is such a wonderful book
it's like by the way brilliant title
life from scratch really just genius pun
there
and so true
thank you vanessa don't forget to grab
your copy of life from scratch family
traditions
that start with you which is such an
empowering way to phrase that it's on
sale now and go to thejewrywhere.com
for this full recipe
[Music]
you